see like I know what joke I want to do
for the opening of this because I can't
hear the name Hilda without thinking of
that one part of Eddie Azores but I
think it was from dressed to kill where
dr. Heimlich is YTM his wife Hilda Oh
Hilda Hilda wake up and I'd like I've
now have now explained the joke and so
if anybody was gonna get it I've really
blown it what is it dr. Hine like you
big waking up person okay yeah I should
have just gone with that heck with it
all right
Hilda the animated show on Netflix I've
had more than a few people recommend it
to me especially after I covered Shira
and I have now seen the entirety of the
season i I don't know if it's intended
to be a multi season show it certainly
could be there's nothing about it that
would preclude it from doing that I just
don't know if they if the intention is
for a second season or if they've knows
so I'm just gonna yell I'll call it
season one so there is a lot about this
that I am inherently going to enjoy so
there is kind of that fairy tale logic
that I've talked about before which is
something that I really appreciate from
things like Pan's Labyrinth the original
labyrinth you know a lot of sort of
animated things aimed for kids sort of
have the the logic of fairy tales which
is not your normal logic like oh well
you know if you do this around this
creature then this happens why who cares
that's just what happens and I always
like that approach the animation style
is really nice I especially like how
smoothly everything moves
I personally speaking I am always
willing to sacrifice highly detailed art
for the sake of smoother movement so
like if I can only have one I will
always take something like this over
what's been going on with a lot of the
DC animated stuff lately where the the
characters are pretty highly detailed
but they moved your
there's fewer frames of animation or you
know they they kind of did that with the
Dragon Prince - I will always prefer a
simplified animation style that moves
smoothly so that's really nice and I
kind of like that they play off the
animation style a little bit at a few
points with some characters flat I was
saying I've got a stick for a hand
because from a drawing perspective they
do so that's kind of cool and fun I like
the the mystical and the magical
elements they're inventive they're
unique but they feel pretty organic to
this world
Hildur herself is a is a good solid
protagonist for a world like this she is
adventurous she's kind-hearted she's
always meaning you know trying to do the
right thing but she's also you know sort
of very self-assured to the point that
kind of gets her in trouble she's always
sure that she can solve the situation
even though sometimes she either can't
or she should be getting help doing it
so with all of this in place why didn't
I like it more now I want to be clear I
don't dislike it I did enjoy it but I
didn't burn through it it took me like
like four or five sittings to get
through this it just didn't grab me on
the level that looking at the component
parts I would have expected it to so
I've kind of been having a think on you
know what what is it about this that
isn't quite working for me I think
initially what I definitely noticed it
took me like three or four episodes to
feel like I was starting to connect with
it at all beyond just sort of finding
the visuals Pleasant and I think a big
part of that delayed engagement and then
sort of that kind of kneecap the whole
thing were you by the end I think I was
pretty much on board by the end but I
would have expected to be much sooner I
think a big part of it is is when you
are dealing with a world this weird
and Lee and this is speaking personally
I'm not saying that this is a
requirement for anyone doing this kind
of story but for me I need to I need to
get centered I need to
I need to know what passes for normal so
that I can know how I meant to be
reacting to various things so when you
have you know a character who is
encountering things like trolls and
she's got a dear Fox twig is adorable I
do love Twix and you know so obviously
this is not just you know a world in
which nobody sees this stuff so she sees
the stuff she encounters this stuff you
know we get the wood man in the first
episode who her mother you know yeah it
doesn't find weird at all okay so it's
not just her but at the same time
there's a vibe early on and how isolated
they're like okay is her and her mother
unique would other people elsewhere know
about this something she's reacting to
she's like oh my gosh what's that I'm
like okay what's the standard base level
knowledge of what magical things you do
and don't know about and I just it took
me about three or four episodes to get
myself orientated for what passed for
normal because she would have reactions
to things and I'd be like well okay
are you surprised is this just oh I
didn't expect to see this or I didn't
know this was possible like I just I
couldn't gauge so if I were to make a
comparison to another animated show that
I know miniseries in this case that I
love and it's got it's got a similar
general feel but like a very different
tone and that's over the garden wall now
over the garden wall is a very weird
mini-series that does a lot of weird
things but pretty much immediately the
main characters the two brothers are
lost meaning okay they're not supposed
to be here and the older brother is
acting as if all this stuff is very
strange okay to them this is not normal
and the younger brother is rolling with
it but you get a sense of his
personality that that's just how he is
it's not that he knows about this stuff
it's just that he isn't bothered by it
so immediately I have a gauge for my
lead characters as to how out of place
or in place they are in the world were
in and that's established like
immediately in that show and I
just lacking that grounding at the front
end of it
now as I said three or four episodes in
it started to click a bit better but
that meant that you usually third or
fourth episode is when I fall in love
with the show that I'm enjoying here
it took three or four episodes for me to
get to the point that I feel like I
should have been at Episode one and so
it wasn't until like episode seven or
eight that I started to really enjoy the
show and that's late in the run of a 13
episode show and again this this is just
me and how I digest these kinds of
things I don't want it to seem like I'm
calling these outright flaws of the show
because I can see reactions and see very
clearly a lot of people like left into
this and embraced it from the get-go
that's phenomenal I all I can do is
explain why it was a little bit of a
harder sell for me I I do like a lot of
the creatures I like that a heck of a
lot of the the mysticism or whatever
feels very similar to stuff that I know
but a little bit different so like we
start with some more basic stuff trolls
elves
oh okay they're setting their own rules
for that but then we get into thing as
well getting to things like the wood man
who's kind of a jerk haha that was that
was an odd thing to have sink in
overtime but you know him the way the
Giants work the the the weather spirits
the the house spirits that we're dealing
with towards the end the tide mice you
know things like this that feel like
they fit the world that was established
early on but also are unique in oh my oh
what's that about and they feel very
true to you know folklore and myths and
fairy tales and it's distinctly possible
that these things were pulled from you
know bits of folklore that I'm just not
familiar with that's possible but it was
kind of cool to feel like I was getting
new folklore because I like that
the supporting cast the mother was fine
the mother was another character that I
felt like I wasn't sure what the show
wanted me to think of her like I got
that she was a good person
and that's
fine but like there are sometimes she's
pushing held us sometimes she's
grounding Hilda's you know like and I'm
not saying that the relationship doesn't
work it feels very genuine but but there
were weird moments like how adamantly
against housing the I was at the Missa
is that what they were called the the
little house fear that that Hilda wanted
to sort of take in and her mother was so
adamantly against that that it felt out
of character because it lacked a firm
explanation of why because she seemed to
roll with most of this mystical stuff so
it's not a case of I don't want this
stuff in my house
and then they but then they didn't
explain why she had such an issue with
these kinds of spirits and again it's
just a weird disconnect that it that it
wasn't addressed um I liked her friends
that that we meet I kind of like that
early on at when she first ends up in
town that we get Trevor introduced and
I'm like oh I don't like this kid and
but you know this is gonna be the
antagonistic thing that becomes a
friendship and a Walden he he was used
just a jerk and we're done with him cool
also I think that's that's kind of
another thing though is the I think it's
another reason I had a hard time
grasping onto this was I had a I had a
hard time understanding the progression
episode 2 episode because this show if
you were to ask me is it serialized or
episodic I kind of got a shrug because
like sometimes it tells stories that are
completely and utterly self-contained
and other times it feels like it's
building to a greater whole but then it
wraps up and cuts off and the next
episode starts with something completely
fresh it kind of it kind of just seems
to jerk around in terms of like Oh will
that finish the story oh but wait we're
gonna end with a cliffhanger for the
following episode like oh but it's it
doesn't feel like it's part of a grander
story in the way that again something
like say over the garden wall was where
you know we know we know the quests we
know the mission their boss they need to
find their way home so whatever
complications they run into that still
the grander story
it's just much more incidental so like
when their house got destroyed in I
think the second episode I was like well
we're gonna have to move into town I'm
like oh it's gonna be adapting to a new
environment story but then she gets
there and the first sort of kids she
runs into she doesn't even Longwood but
then she makes friends pretty much right
away by Episode four and she's a little
bit in the you know I wish that I was
still in the woods but it doesn't that
doesn't feel like I'm much of a theme
across the maybe that's the thing and
and maybe I missed it but I couldn't
wrap my head around a thematic through
line and it's structured in such a way
that makes me feel like there either is
supposed to be one there or there is one
there and I missed it
because there isn't really a narrative
through line yet it does still feel like
they're doing all this stuff that feels
like connective tissue but it's not
narrative lis so I'm thinking well let's
make somatic connective tissue but again
like maybe I just missed it
maybe I I have to assume there's
something here I'm missing there's
something I'm not getting
and again for all the like sort of over
dissection I'm doing of my issues with
it it's still good and I would recommend
it it's fun it's lighted the characters
are enjoyable like I said I really like
the art style and I love the imagination
on display I'm gonna give my I'm gonna
see if my daughter enjoys it all cuz I
think it's the kind of thing she would
like but for me it just it felt ever so
slightly off for reasons that I'm just
having a hard time pinning down all
right a quick addendum to held up
because I have now actually started
watching it with my daughter and she is
enjoying it quite a bit which I
suspected she would it was a pretty easy
stuff pretty much as soon as I told her
about twig and I said there's a creature
and it called the deer Fox and it's a
little white fox with antlers and she
was like I want to see that so I know
might get pretty well um so she's
digging the heck out of it and I have to
say I am enjoying it much more on every
watch which isn't all that shocking
given my issue sort of would like
finding my foot
my footing with the thing because on a
rewatch I've already done that so I'm
able to appreciate these early episodes
more and better I'm not gonna read you
know the reason I'm adding this as an
addendum instead of rear according all
of the the entire review is because I
still think my feelings
I stand by them because I'm always
hesitant to say it's good on a rewatch
because that's a that's kind of a big
commitment to ask of people especially
on like a show as opposed to a movie
that you have to watch it try it twice
to get the full appreciation but some
things are like that and actually what I
told Liz that I was having a much better
experience with it the second time
because I understood it better she was
like oh so it's like it's like the big
lebowski of animated Netflix shows I was
like you know for how divergent the
content is that's not a terrible
comparison so you know take that for
what it's worth and that's my little
addition so that's my thoughts on Hilda
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down to comments let's talk
about it a whole bunch of stuff you can
do such as the click the buttons or the
links there's a link to my patreon you
know if you want to support me that way
if not though don't sweat it there's a
whole bunch of other stuff you can do
down there you don't want to click on
any of it that's fine too because at the
end of the day you're the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]